president biden heads to western europe
this morning where he will meet with
nato european union and g7 allies to
find a solution to the growing crisis
there the president will also visit
poland where more than 2 million
ukrainian refugees have fled since the
russian invasion ed o'keefe is in
brussels he's with the president where
the president will start his trip ed
this trip seems to come together very
quickly from those on the outside
looking in
it sure has gail good to see you in fact
it's come together so quickly that nato
is officially calling this an
extraordinary summit because it normally
takes months if not a year to arrange
for the 30 world leaders to get together
here there will also be meetings as you
mentioned of the g7 and the european
commission and what's on the agenda well
among other things they're going to be
talking about new sanctions against
russia and also finding ways to bolster
the ones that have already been put in
place to make sure that oligarchs and
others being targeted don't evade the
punishments the president is also
expected to talk about making sure that
europe becomes less dependent on russian
oil and natural gas also likely to be
some talk about military deployments by
nato closer to the region and ukraine's
leader zilinski is expected to virtually
address the meetings remember ukraine
has been pushing to become a member of
the european union and nato but is not
currently a member of either alliance
hey ed the president's also heading to
ukraine's neighbor poland i know you
know that but what do we expect from
that part of the trip
yeah remember they are on the front
lines and they've absorbed more than two
million refugees since this crisis began
so the visit is in essence a thank you
to poland for shouldering so much of
this humanitarian crisis the white house
says the president will meet with
poland's president he'll give formal
remarks about how the free world is
responding to the crisis and helping
ukraine and don't be surprised though
nothing's been officially announced that
he meets at some point with ukrainian
refugees the irony here that many
americans back home of course are
starting to go back to work after the
pandemic well this is a president who
says he prefers face-to-face diplomacy
over those virtual calls he's been
holding over the last several months
he'll have plenty of time for gripping
grinning handshakes and face-to-face
conversation in the coming days gail
face to face always very important thank
you ed